[Music]
hi folks
thanks for coming my name is Manish I'm
a product manager on Google compute
engine and today we're gonna be talking
about saving money on compute engine
before we dive into the topic there is a
Dory for this session my amazing
colleagues Scott's gonna be moderating
it so if any questions pop up while
we're going through the talk feel free
to post those questions there and we'll
answer some of those questions as well
as take some live questions at these
remotes at the end of the session so
wasting money on cloud is a very real
problem
our friends at write scale do an annual
survey basically every year they do this
and just like last year they found that
35% of cloud spend is being lost that's
a very large number and what's causing
it is a host of different things right
it may be that you're running instances
or resources that you no longer need
anymore or you've over-provision
resources or you just haven't bought the
right discounts for the things that you
are running today but regardless 35%
over the past two years straight is a
pretty big number and it's not because
customers don't care the majority of
respondents in this survey cite cloud
optimization cloud cost as a top concern
yet the number is still so big and the
reason for that is it's not easy right
like cloud is a really dynamic place
things are constantly changing there's
new features coming to compute engine
every week or every month and then your
actual environment you have resources
coming and going at whatever churn rate
you have no idea at some other times so
it can be really hard to keep up
so in today's talk what we're gonna
focus on are what are some of the common
patterns for waste in terms of cloud
spend and what you can do about it we'll
tackle that in four set four sections
the first will talk about how Google
thinks about pricing products the second
is we'll think about we'll talk about
understanding what are the resources
that you're actually paying for if you
don't understand what the resources
you're paying for are it's really hard
to optimize those
cause and then we'll talk about those
common areas where waste happens and
what are tactical things you can do to
sort of remove that waste and then
finally we'll close on optimizing the
types of discounts you can make or
purchase to help optimize the actual
resources that you're running so let's
get started we'll talk about pricing
principles first so when we Google cloud
think about pricing products we try to
keep the three principles in mind some
simple flexible and fair
now these principles can mean a lot of
different things to different people so
let me talk through each one of these
and describe what it means to us simple
means powerful enough to meet your needs
without being unnecessarily complex and
so that mean that doesn't mean that a
five-year-old should be able to
understand your cloud bill but it also
doesn't mean that you should have should
you should be required to have a PhD in
finance to figure out your cloud bill
and so one of the features that we have
that we launched last year is something
called resource based pricing resource
based pricing basically charges or
meters usage against each resource as an
independent SKU so it's super easy to
figure out where you're spending your
money so you could look at it and say oh
I'm spending X dollars on Coors Y
dollars on RAM and some money on some
premium OS licenses
there's no weird bundles to sort of
reverse engineer there's no hitting cost
it makes things super simple and easy
and transparent to figure out what's
going on on your bill flexible so we get
it things change over time and you
shouldn't be scared to make a decision
today and be punished if things change
in the future
so this is something that we spend a lot
of time on with our pricing models we
think really hard about how do we make
things flexible enough so that our
pricing models can evolve and adapt to
your evolving and add out you're
evolving workloads and change your
changing workloads one example of this
is something that we call committed use
discounts and the idea with committed
use discounts is you you purchase a
aggregate aggregate commitment for X
amount of resources say a thousand cores
in specific region and in exchange you
say I'm going to I'm going to pay for
that for one or three
years and you can get some fairly deep
discounts this way but what makes
committed use discounts flexible is that
we're not asking you for a specific
machine shape or a specific zone or a
specific operating system or network
type or anything like that you're just
telling us what region and the amount of
cores and now you can run whatever VMs
you want so VMs can come and go you can
change shapes you can change the zones
within the region
you can change operating systems those
commitments that you made on day one
will continue to apply so the whole goal
here so that you shouldn't have to feel
afraid to make some of these commitments
on our platform and then finally fair
fair first and foremost means a low
competitive price always what it also
means though is that if we see that
you're wasting money in some way for
example if you're running an over
provision instance and we notice it
we're gonna get in your face and we're
gonna tell you about it so that you can
take action we call that instance right
sizing another thing that we do or it
would sort of driven from our fairness
ideal is if you happen to do something
with your workload and it saves Google
money it's only fair that we pass those
savings on to you so if you for example
if you run a resource for an entire
month
that gives efficiency to Google and so
Google should pass some of those savings
on to you and so we do exactly that was
something called sustained use discounts
you don't need to tell us anything you
just run your workload and if you happen
to run it for some steady-state within
the month you'll automatically get
discounts and this commitment to
simplicity flexibility and fairness it's
not something that you find with all
cloud providers and definitely not
something that you've seen from all
cloud providers from day one so let's
let's move on to the second section
we're gonna start talking about
understanding what are you actually
getting charged for in terms of the
resources that you run within compute
engine so at a high level you can group
the resources into two buckets the base
VM which is the cores and RAM and the
attachable resources so these are things
like GPUs persistent disk licensing and
there's a whole bunch of other little
not little but other resources like
local SSD
so one of the things here is one of the
core things around compute engine is
providing visibility into the resources
that you're running and so when you're
trying to optimize your cost you want to
understand where you're spending your
money so a lot of compute engine
customers spend most of their spend ends
upon their base VM the cores and RAM but
there are attachable resources that can
be quite expensive like a V 100 GP for
example and so optimizing your GPU spend
can also have a material impact on your
overall bill and so with resource based
pricing which is something that we
talked about a little bit earlier it's
really easy to get a picture of what
you're actually spending your money on
and so you can kind of stack rank and
focus where do I need to spend the most
attention initially which could be your
cores and RAM or if you're a heavy GPU
user you may be wanting to optimize your
GPS so how do you figure out what's
actually running right now so if you
want to understand what's happening at a
point in time right now you can take
advantage of our instance list and
describe api's so with the list API you
get a list of all of the instances that
are currently running on on your on your
project and then you can use the disk
instance described API to see what
exactly that instance is and so the cost
driving fields here are things like
machine type right so this is the base
VM the core in RAM there's also
accelerator type and accelerator account
so these are the the GPUs that are
running in the number of GPUs and the
type of GPU there's your disk and so
there could be multiple disk objects
within that resource in the API so you
could have persistent disk multiple
persistent disks attached to your VM or
you can have a local SSD disk as well
and locus ISTE can also be a fairly
expensive resource and then you can also
take a look at what's running on - in
terms of the licensing or the premium OS
is attached to the VMs that you're
running so seeing what's running at sort
of that moment in time is useful but a
lot of cloud environments you're what
ran what's running right now is not
indicative of what ran four months ago
or over that period of time between four
months
go in today and so for that type of
historical analysis we have a really
really awesome tool it's called bigquery
billing export once you enable this this
export basically happens is all the
usage that is charged against your
charge against your project and all the
different SKUs will get logged and put
into a bigquery data set and then you
can do analysis on that data set for
whatever time frame you want the main
thing that I would point out is that
it's not sort of retroactive so once you
enable it that is when the data will
start getting stored so if you're not
going to get historical data if you
haven't activated it yet and so the idea
here is really simple it's a really
simple example that's up here you can
ask the data set to give you all of the
SKUs associated with compute engine for
a specific project or for a billing
account or multiple projects if you want
and then you group by the SKU view name
and then sum up the cost and then sort
in descending order by the cost and what
that will give you in terms of an export
is exactly all of the specific resources
that you're paying from the most
expensive on your bill all the way to
your least expensive so in this example
it's a bunch of n1 standard cores some
n1 standard Ram and then there's some
v100 GPUs running so this is a really
really powerful tool so something I
really encourage you folks that turn on
when you when you start creating your
projects or if you already have a
project turn it on it's a great way to
sort of analyze what's happening and
assess what you should do in terms of
optimizing your cloud costs so now I
want to introduce a fictional company I
took some of the usage patterns from a
real company and applied it here but
this is not a real company
it's example Inc they just ramped up on
compute engine they're spending about
1.4 million dollars a year now they've
done no work to optimize their bills so
nothing they just started creating
instances so it's probably a lot of
low-hanging fruit here and the purpose
of this example company is to help us a
lot help illustrate some of the what an
optimization can do on the overall bill
for some for a semi real example and
just to make sure that we're all kind of
aligned so they're spending 1.4 million
they've got a whole bunch of cores so
they have 230 VMs running across
from VM shapes they've got some GPUs
just 8v 100s they've got about 120
terabytes of PD SSD and the running also
they're also running some Windows
workloads so let's let's take example
link on the journey of doing some cost
optimization so the first thing we would
say to example Inc
is pick the right size for your workload
instance size for your workload and
compute engine offers a great deal of
flexibility here with something that we
call custom machine shapes and a lot of
other cloud providers what they require
you to do is choose between a fixed list
of predefined machine shapes and
sometimes what that means is that you
have to pick a machine that is bigger
than what you need in terms of cores RAM
or local SSD and that's not that's
basically waste with custom machine
types what you can do is pick the right
amount of cores the writer right amount
of memory and not have to overpay for
the cores and RAM that you would have to
do with a predefined machine type so a
couple of caveats with custom machine
types there are some restrictions so if
you want a custom machine type you have
to do it in increments of 2v CPUs so 2 4
6 8 and then point to 5 gigabytes of
memory even with those sort of caveats
or restrictions custom machine types are
significantly more flexible than most
predefined machine types that you see
out there so there's real cost savings
here if you leverage custom machine
types so if you have VMs running right
now or you're going to be launching
instances in the future think about
right sizing them you may be over
provisioning these VMs and there's
significant savings here for you
potentially so predefined machine types
are generally most predefined machine
types are in shapes of what we call
powers of two and so that's 2 4 8 16 32
64 and the reason that is is that it
makes bin packing on the cloud provider
side really really easy so it's great
for the provider but
not great for you because you're forced
to pay for resources that you don't
actually need so let's take an example
let's say you want to run you need 20
cores in the old powers of 2 world what
you'd be stuck with is a 32 core VM and
that means you're paying for 12 extra
cores that you don't don't need so that
doesn't seem really fair from our
pricing principle perspective right so
take advantage of custom machine types
take a look at what you can do to shrink
down your VMs to the right size so in
order to do that actual steps there's a
little code snippet here the idea here
is you stop the instance so there is an
outage you would change the shape of the
VM and then you start the instance back
up and it would reconnect all your PDS
and all of that so there is an outage so
you want to be you know do it during
your maintenance windows or if it's not
critical as a dev test you can just do
it when whenever it makes sense so
figuring out if you are over
provisioning an instance is not
necessarily a simple task right
workloads can change over time so you'd
have to have a lot of telemetry you'd be
trying to see what's happening to the VM
and trying to figure out oh should I
write size it or not so following our
principles around fairness we watch
instances we see the utilization rates
and so if we notice a VM that's being
underutilized or even over utilized
we're gonna tell you we're gonna get in
your face we're gonna tell you about it
and so we call this right sizing
recommendations this is available in GA
today you can just log into the cloud
console go to the instance to the
compute engine instance page and you'll
see a list of recommendations there and
with a push of a button you can either
accept or decline the recommendation and
go ahead and do it again there's an
outage here so don't like just start
clicking things but it's basically
propagated here so you can see what's
happening so doing that is great but
it's still very manual right so you have
to log into the cloud console and one by
one collect the instances and figure out
what action you want to take and so
today what I'm excited to announce is
that we're going to be enabling
programmatic access to these
right-sizing recommendation
so we call it the right sizing API and
the idea here is you can query the API
right sizing API get a list of
recommendations all programmatically and
then programmatically decide if you want
to take the recommendation or not and
then apply the right sizing and so that
would be a stop or resize and then a
restart and then you can take that
program that you've written and schedule
it so it runs daily or hourly or
whatever it might be to keep up with the
churn of instances that are coming on
the fly
so that you can stay ahead of all of the
new instances that are getting created
so you don't have to keep logging in
every day and doing right sizing
manually so it's pretty cool
it's in alpha today and it's coming to
beta soon so keep an eye out for if you
find this interesting so going back to
an example Inc example Inc realized that
they've been running 96 core VMs when
they only really needed 72 core VMs and
they're tricking the memory in the same
proportion as well and as a result of
that change in right sizing they're able
to save about 5% on their total bill but
they're not done there yet right so they
have a whole bunch of other resources so
now they're moving on and now they're
looking at some of the attached
resources that attach to the base VM so
that second bucket of resources that we
talked about and so some of these
resources can be very expensive so gpgpu
so localized to see these are examples
of potentially very expensive resources
where small amount of waste can accrue
to a very large amount of cost on your
bill
and again the powers of 2 are striking
here again right
a lot of compute engine provides a great
deal more flexibility with GPUs then
you'll find with other providers and so
an example here is let's say you have a
use case where you need 64 cores of VMs
I'm sorry 64 core VM in the power of 2
world there's a fixed ratio if you want
64 cores you have to get 8 V 100 GPUs
but let's say you only need 2 well you
don't have that option in the predefined
world or the powers of 2 world with
compute engine you can go ahead and
create that 64 core VM and attach a 2
core of V 100 GPU
in this significance I mean there's
significant savings here right so just
looking at the GPU alone it's $20 per
hour versus five dollars an hour so
example Inc took a look at this and they
realized that they could shrink their 8v
100 to 4-view 100's and as a result they
sent they saved another around five
percent so these two steps they're now
saving about 10% on their total spend
right now so they're also using
persistent disk and persistent disk is a
it's a cheaper resource for sure and you
can have a lot of persistent disk and it
doesn't add up to that much when
especially when you're comparing it to
local SSD or GPUs or even the base core
DRAM but a lot of VMs have a lot of
disks and a lot of cloud workloads have
a lot of churn where instances are
coming and going rapidly and so one of
the things that we've seen from some
customers is you end up in a situation
where instances get deleted but
persistent disks that were attached to
the instance don't get deleted and so
you end up with a whole bunch of
orphaned persistent disks floating
around and you can imagine if you don't
pay attention this for a long period of
time and you have a lot of churn
instances are coming and going you could
end up with you know thousands hundred
thousands of persistent disks or you may
just start hitting your quota limits to
prevent you from going too high so one
one wreck one one tactical thing you can
do here is when you're creating your
disk or your instance or attaching the
disk to an instance you can set a flag
to have it Auto delete and so when the
instance is deleted the persistent disks
that you've marked this flag on will
also get deleted so it's a great way to
prevent this orphanage can be happening
one caution on this is it's a very
powerful tool right it's a very very
dangerous thing like in the sense of if
you delete the VM and you actually want
the persistent disk there's a bunch of
warnings that will pop up in the console
and in the g-cloud interface and all of
that but if you keep going to yes yes
yes that disk is going to get deleted
and if you actually do need the data
that's a really bad situation
so use this use this flag cautiously
especially if you have different people
creating instances and different people
deleting instance they you may not have
sort of you may have the right hand left
hand is you happening but this is one
thing that we've seen customers leverage
to kind of prevent an excess waste in
terms of PD so another thing you can do
is take advantage of snapshots so
snapshots are 85 percent cheaper than a
running PD SSD for the same amount of
storage and so with a snapshot what you
can do is take a snapshot of your disk
and then delete the snapshot I'm sorry
didn't elite the the persistent disk and
the use case there is is you have some
pd's just floating around that you don't
need but you want the data you're not
attached to any instance so why not just
take the snapshot save the data and then
when you need the data you can rehydrate
that snapshot back into a disk and then
attach it to a running instance and then
the final final thing here on sort of
these are very tactical things but the
final thing here is PD supports two
types of disks PD SSD which is you know
SSD and then PD standard PD standard is
significantly cheaper than PD SSD and
not all workloads need the performance
characteristics of SSDs so take a look
at your workloads and identify where it
makes sense to use SSD and where it
doesn't make sense and convert over to
PD standard where possible so we're
going back to example link again example
link took a look at their 120 terabytes
and they realize that about 14 terabytes
of the PD SSD that they've provisioned
which was basically because they had a
bunch of scripts and everyone just
launched their instances and they just
got PTSD they realized that they could
cut 14 terabytes and convert that to PD
standard so that results in like a 1 to
2 percent increase and savings now so
smaller than the larger instances but
that's kind of the point right
like you're gonna want to spend your
time on where you're spending the most
money first to get to your best bang for
your buck and then go down that list of
sort of the higher the sort of the most
expensive resource all the way
to the least expensive resource so now
they're at 11% which is not bad right
and we've been at this for maybe 20
minutes now we've saved them to 11
percent off of 1.5 million not bad
another thing you can do is leverage
preemptable resources and so parental
resources is is a it's basically our
most discounted offering it provides up
to eighty percent off of normal
on-demand prices but it comes with some
slightly different characteristics it
will it the the resources act and look
just like a normal resource or the
performance will be the same
availability is the same however you can
only keep the resource for 24 hours and
there's a slight chance that you may be
preempted before the 24 hours so you may
be asking whoa like this who would use
this right if you have applications that
can checkpoint and tolerate sort of vm's
coming and going and restarting at a
certain checkpoint this is a great way
to save a lot of money on some of your
workloads so some examples here are sort
of patchwork loads rendering things like
that use priam preemptable resources
heavily alright so we're gonna switch to
something a little more
Nishi now and when we talk about
licensing there's two types of licenses
I want to talk about today the first is
the CPU based licenses so you may have
some software that you've purchased that
the the software provider says you can
run it in the cloud but you have to
license it based on the HV CPU that
you're running you also may have some
workloads that are heavily memory bound
and not compute bound so databases are a
great example of this where you need a
whole boat whole boatload of memory and
not a lot of compute power and so we
have a feature called extended memory
that's directly addressed at this type
of use case and the idea here is is that
extended memory allows you to create VMs
with much higher memory - V CPU ratios
than you can get with custom machine
types or predefined machine types so for
example you could have a VM with one v
CPU and 500 gigabytes of RAM
and so if you were to take that use case
with a V CPU license you would be
responsible to pay for one v CPU license
but your workload in your database would
still have 500 gigabytes of memory to
work with one thing I would call out
here is there is an extra cost for using
extended memory so you're gonna want to
do the math and say what is the cost per
V CPU that I add what is the cost and
then what is the cost for enabling
extended memory as I do that math and
many customers that I've talked to for
certain software licenses extended
memory makes just a whole lot of sense
because the V CPU license is dwarfed the
cost of the actual VM itself another
thing another type of license that I
want to talk to the second type of
license I want to talk about is server
bound licenses so these are licenses
that require you to license the physical
cores or physical sockets of a server
this is not something that you could do
on compute engine before you may have
noticed in the the keynote today we
announced support for bringing on your
bring your own license on sole tenant
nodes and so the idea here is we're now
going to expose the physical
characteristics of our sole tenant nodes
so you'll know that there's X sockets Y
court Y physical cores which means now
if you have some of these server bound
licenses you can bring them onto these
sole tenant nodes so Windows is a great
example of this Windows Server Windows
Server is a great example of this so
before this feature if you wanted to run
Windows on compute engine you would have
to buy a license from compute engine and
even though you may already have Windows
Server licenses on you that you
purchased through Microsoft or through
one of their third-party authorized
dealers which is kind of wasteful right
you're basically paying for two licenses
you can only use one of them it doesn't
seem super fair so what you can do now
is you can take the licenses that you
have on parameter that you've bought and
you can bring them over to compute
engine via this this feature sole tenant
BYO l and so the example here is these
Microsoft licenses can be quite
expensive so just on the server license
alone it's more than the instance cost
itself so you could save more than
55% on compute engine today if you just
bring your own licenses for Windows
Server but you can imagine that this
starts to get really really cheaper if
you think that you're running say sequel
server Microsoft sequel server on it as
well so if you remember we talked about
example Inc example Inc did have a small
footprint of Windows licenses so they
had a hundred and ninety-two Windows
core licenses that they were purchasing
through compute engine with this new byl
feature they basically spun up some sole
tenant nodes they launched their Windows
VMs into the sole tenant nodes and as a
result they stopped paying Google on
compute engine for these Windows
licenses and instead are able to reuse
the licenses that they have today and
the savings here add up to another two
to three I think three to four percent
and so now we're up to about 15% total
savings here so we've gone through a
whole bunch of different things in terms
of being able to reduce your bill from a
resource perspective and so the whole
point of this is to take all of the
waste that's happening with the
resources that you're running and bring
it down to just exactly what you need
right and you know you'll be some noise
there but that's the whole point of the
that section 3 is to figure out how do
you shrink this down so that you're what
you're using and what you're being
charged for is the minimum amount that
you actually need once you do that then
it's time to start thinking about ok now
I've got this minimum amount of usage
how do i optimize the discounts
available to me so the first one we
talked a little bit about it but it's
super simple and easy is sustained use
discounts and the basic premise here is
the more you run the more you save up to
30% off if you run the resource for more
than or for the entire month and this is
something that we've continued this is
something that we launched many years
ago and we've continued to invest in it
to try and make it more flexible and
more
and so today what you can do now is you
can start and stop VMs freely you can
change the shape of your VMs so you can
go from N 1 for N 1 standard for 2 N 1
standard 16 the sustain use discount
will continue to accrue on a core and
RAM basis independent of those two
things and you can change zones within a
region so this gives you a whole
boatload of flexibility with sustain use
discount so you can run these different
instances things can change over time
and at the end of the month we'll look
at what you ran and if you ran a
resource across different zones in the
same region and different VM types but
if that thing ran that core ran for a
full 30 days or 31 days you'll get 30%
off and so we're going to do that
calculation for you and it's only fair
right we're going to give you the
optimal discount based on the usage that
you're getting so it's a little bit of
complexity that I want to add here
that's has been recently added is we do
split sustained use discount into two
buckets today so we have something
called the general purpose bucket and
the memory optimized bucket so
general-purpose VMs are the n1 standard
the n1 high mem and then one high CPU as
well as custom machine types and sole
tenant nodes and memory optimized our
memory optimized VM so these are megaman
1 megohm M and N 1 Ultraman and so what
I mean by separate buckets is that when
I was saying that you could change VM
shapes if you were to change between a
general-purpose VM and a memory
optimized VM the sustained use discounts
don't stack these are two different
pools or usage graphs that we look at to
optimize in terms of cost so I think an
example might make this a little clearer
so here's an example you're you're
running an n1 standard for for half the
month and then you know there's a
there's some event you get some whole
bunch of new traffic pop in and as a
result you increase the size of your VM
to an n1 standard 16 so it's only fair
you ran 4 cores for the entire month
right
so sustained use discounts will give you
30% discount on those 4 cores and for
the remaining 12 cores that are there
that work that got added as part of the
n1 standard 16 that ran for half a month
so you'll get around
percent discount which is the half half
the month type discount so going going
along so now if we have two separate
sustained use buckets let's say you
started with an N one standard four and
then you convert it to N 1 megohm M
whatever so different different buckets
sustained use buckets in that scenario
you would only get 1/2 from half a month
sustained use discount for the N one
standard and then half a month discount
for the mega man so you only get to ten
percent discount you won't get that for
those four cores won't get the 30
percent so something to be aware of so
there's some restrictions in terms of
the different instances that you change
to there are some restrictions that are
happening there so sustained use
discounts is pretty cool because you
don't have to send any signal to Google
and say hey I'm gonna run this and you
still get up to a 30 percent discount if
you happen to run for the entire month
but in some use cases you may actually
know that you have some steady-state
workloads that are gonna run for one or
three years or even longer and in those
scenarios you should be able to get an
even lower price or a bigger discount
and so for that we have something called
committed use discounts and the idea
with committed use discounts is in
exchange for a 1 or 3 year commitment
you get a deeply discounted price and so
for 1 year you'll get 37 percent off and
for 3 year you get 55 percent off and we
tried to make committed use discounts
very similar to sustain use discounts in
terms of flexibility and fairness so
with a committed use discount you tell
us in aggregate what you want so you
could say I want 10,000 cores and 5,000
or 50 thousand gigabytes of RAM you
don't have to tell us the Machine shapes
or specific zones or operating systems
and so as you start spinning up those
VMs if things have to change those VMs
shut down and come back or you change
instance types within the general
purpose pool or the memory optimized
pool the discounts will just accrue
another use case that we've seen is and
this is I think it's pretty neat is that
when you get to like really large-scale
although any single user or project may
have a lot of volatility when you start
to add a huge amount of projects and a
huge amount of usage you'll start
these customers will start to notice
that there are sort of these low water
marks that they can by community use
discounts out so they're not actually
buying for a specific workload that's
that they know is steady they just know
that in aggregate across all the noise
within their organization they're always
going to have 50,000 cores running and
they may burst ten thousand or a hundred
thousand quarters at any point but they
know that they're never gonna go below
that so it's a it's an ideal thing to
purchase so committed use discounts is
maybe one of the most popular pricing
models we've seen in the last on compute
engine for the last couple years and so
today I'm really excited something that
I've been working on I'm really excited
to announce that we're expanding
community use discounts to additional
resources so we're gonna support GPUs as
well as local SSD and so it works very
similar to committed use discounts for
cores in RAM so you get you can do a
one-year or three-year and you'll get
the similar discounts 37% for one year
55% for three year and we're gonna
support all of the the GPU types that we
have today so the the k80 the P for the
P 100 excuse me and the view 100 and the
T for something that we announced I
think today so that's coming very soon
and we'll be supporting that as well so
if you are running GPU workloads that
have some sort of steady state workload
this is a great way to save some money
so if you know you're gonna run it for
three years or even one year it makes
sense to buy these
I'm also excited so something I also
have been working on I'm also excited to
introduce a brand new billable resource
that you have to worry about
they're called zonal reservations and
the idea here is they provide peace of
mind that resources will be available
for you when and where you want them and
so the idea here is is you can say I
need to make sure that I always have 101
standard 32s in US central 1a so it's a
specific zone and a specific machine
shape you can create these reservations
and so long as we grant the reservation
you now know that those resources are
there for you and you can convert them
into running instances whenever you want
and there's a bunch of different use
cases here some of the use cases are you
know for example let's say you want to
do a patch and so you're patching and
you're doing a rolling patch of some
instance get deleted you want to make
sure that you have enough resources to
make sure that you can complete the
operation and come back in a healthy
state so that's one of the things that's
going on there so one of the things that
we tried to do really hard with
reservations was again live by those
three principles that we talked about
simplicity flexibility and fairness and
so these reservations are effectively
just like running instances from compute
engine perspective and so any of the
resources that any of the discounts you
may have purchased already like a
committed use discount or even sustained
use discounts should just apply like
it's a running instance so if you
purchase some community use discounts
you can imagine that these reservations
look and act just like an instance from
a discounting perspective so if you
happen to say I bought a CD for this
running instance and I now want to make
it a reservation you can do that and
your discounts will still the committed
Eustace council still work and so
similarly on a sustained use perspective
sustained use discount perspective will
have reservations for general purpose
PMS as well as memory optimized VMs and
so when you create those reservations
they'll feed into those two different
sustained use buckets that we talked
about
another new feature that we're adding
and so this one's an out so I should I
should I should go back so these are
these are coming to beta very soon in
the next couple weeks you'll see this
become available and another feature
that is currently in alpha today is what
we call committed use discount analysis
reports and so these are first class
reports within the the the billing UI
within cloud console and they're meant
to help you understand if you've
purchased some CDs it'll help you
understand what the financial impact of
those things are so you can get a sense
of am i utilizing my CU d or my under
utilizing my CU d should i be should I
be buying more CDs that type of thing so
that takes me to the end of the session
so there's a few there's a few breakout
sessions I want to call out the main one
that I think is super interesting that I
think folks will think will resonate
with folks in a room is a cst-100 301
and so one of my colleagues will be
talking about many of the sort of
cost-saving things that we've talked
about that we were doing sort of a
manual way and doing it in sort of an
automated way so there's a whole bunch
of cool demos and code snippets that are
going to be available there so strongly
encourage you if you found this
interesting to check that out it should
be super cool and then I like to just
thank everyone for attending and think
the the production team in the back as
well you guys are awesome thank you so
much and then one sort of bookkeeping
item there is a survey for all of the
sessions so if you take some time please
fill it out positive or negative
feedback is more than welcome I'd love
to hear what everyone thought so now
let's open it up to questions
yeah is there is anyone want to come
down or we can start with the dory I
think we have someone maybe not I'm not
gonna I'm calling you out sorry
alright let's start at the dory then
cool there were there was one question
on the dory
that was answered later in the slides
but it's worth calling out just to
re-emphasize the question is for
instance right-sizing what other ways
can this be can captured outside of the
console can this be can this be an event
on pub/sub or exposed via another API
and I think you answered that a little
bit later in the talk where it is the
right-sizing api is available now as an
alpha api and we'll be launching the
beta soon so you'll be able to consume
those programmatically via that API yeah
exactly it's it's going to be super cool
and if you're interested in the Alpha
like just just reach out it's my my last
name at Google calm to just reach out
and we can try and get you guys into the
Alpha go ahead most of our compute
engines are ICP based and ICP only
certified this is there I saw the
flexibility of nodes versus course
memory versus cores because most of our
systems are non production only the
production has to be standardized and
SCP certified all the other ones we can
really manipulate it the way we want is
that something we should look into or is
this something that SCP is a Scott you
may know this better than me but I think
it really depends on the use case right
so if you are doing sort of a test
environment you probably want the
environment to be very similar to what
you're actually gonna be deploying to
production if you're doing some toy
stuff it seems reasonable that you can
at least play with it but again you have
to talk with it I think you have to make
sure that he's okay with allowing you to
do some of this stuff for example like
obviously they the quality system has to
be as production but for projects it
testing the data is the same size as
production however the compute engine or
the CPUs that extra
that we see that maybe we can minimize
yeah is something that all everything
that basically question everything you
said to the computation does apply to
their CP compute engines or the guess SI
p templates that we use I think for the
non production use get workloads yeah I
believe that's non production use cases
for the SI p software and deployment is
all that stuff supplies I think the the
key with the SI p certification and then
the the trigger of the licensing is like
the production workloads require a
specific you know machine shape a
specific configuration of PD SSD etc and
a specific guest OS like you know
celeste for SI p etc that's the that's
what triggers like kind of the
production you know aspect of your SI p
deployment and that's where I think the
specific machine shapes and all those
config needs to be met before
they support that as a production
workload and then they also production
licensing oh I see so API access to the
bigquery export I mean I think the the
data we want to share right so
fundamentally like this is just a sort
of prioritization thing right so I think
as we get more feedback of this type of
thing these are things that we can add
and so I can't specifically speak to
what we're doing but so the I think just
so I just so super clear to me the the
ask is the ability to query the instance
type from the EPA okay okay so it's not
actually so it's not about the bigquery
export it's about being able to look at
what's running right now call the api's
instance that list and describe thank
you so there's another question from the
dory are you going to allow moving
committed used discounts between
projects so i can't announce anything
specifically but this is something that
we hear constantly and our roadmap is
driven by customer asks so just keep
your ears out any plans to include PD
SSDs and CD like offer CDs for PD SSD
yeah I think so there's something that
I've been discussing with our internal
team in terms of how we want to expand
community use discounts beyond just sort
of compute engine in general and so this
is something that we are looking at
there's nothing you know immediate
that's coming but totally totally get it
I think some of the challenges on the PD
side is that PD tends to be fairly cheap
already so I'm not sure if we're we're
gonna be able to offer say like a fifty
five percent off discount for a
three-year commitment on some PD so
there's some viability things that we
need to look at there and the last one
there it's not quite a question but it's
maybe it's something that you can
provide some insight into you need to
have an SI agreement with Microsoft to
gain mobility also there are
restrictions on Microsoft applications
that actually have mobility rights os is
not one of them and then they provide a
link for more information like that I'm
not sure what that translates to yeah
yeah so it's super confusing I get it
and so as part of the BYO well launch
the beta launch that went out today
actually there's there's gonna be
documentation that talks about what's
what's allowed what's not allowed and
gives guidance in the end you do need to
look at your EA with Microsoft and make
sure that it isn't as in compliance and
compliance but a lot of these days tend
to be standard language and so there
will be material as part of the Sultan
and BYO L documentation that talks about
this in detail
[Music]